e
e e
come to water members take your seats
members take your
seats the chair recognizes a member from
Auburn representative Osborne who mules
the house adjourned from the session of
January 9th 2025 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I those
oppos nay the eyes have it and the house
is adjourned the house will attend to a
Prayer by representative Alexis Simpson
from
exor good morning
everyone let us take a moment to bring
our hearts
together I usually have a few minutes to
prepare but I'm on the Fly today so
let's first just all take a deep breath
together great okay let us
pray Eternal one we give you thanks for
bringing us all to this space
together we know we all come with other
people and other communities on our
minds and we ask you to hold all those
dear that we are praying for and
thinking of this morning as we do our
work
together we pray that in all that we do
today we would remember the sacred in
each of us when we are speaking together
and we pray that our work will be
efficient today so that we may be safe
in our travels home please protect all
those who are working to keep the road
safe for us and who are making the food
for us today and who are keeping our
homes warm for us
today may you be present in our time in
our speeches in our conversations in our
thoughts and in our vote
and we all say together
amen chair recognizes the member from
bosan representative Ricky Dev void who
will lead us in the Pledge of
Allegiance
Al the United States of America and to
the for it stands one nation under God
with liy and justice for
all the chair recognizes Melissa ellman
from conquer will now sing our national
anthem
see
the
light what so Pro the
head at the
Twilight
last who broad stripes and bright
STS through
[Music]
the
we
streaming and The Rock
bur
in give proof through the
night that a flag was
[Music]
the of
the and the
home of the
[Applause]
the house to attend to request for Lees
of
absence Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives Burch Bill Boyd Cahill
Corman Greg H Haskins manahar Lawrence
Miner parall wine Pearson Pressa sakas
Jared Sullivan tensar Varney the day
important business layward Bay Bolton
William Dolan England Lewis lungren
mandab bomb Stephanie P Southworth and
sudor the day illness in the family
Representatives Grossman Howland and
Judy the day death in the family
Representatives Buco and
Weber these leaves of absent shall be
granted with otherwise ordered by the
house a house to tend to an introduction
of guests Mr Speaker speaker please
welcome an Marie and John piantadosi
guests of Representative devoid Anthony
Henry and Thomas hosy guests of
Representatives tibo Brendan Malone
guest of Representative Mark PR they are
with us in the gallery
today Welcome to the New Hampshire house
before we go on a lot are wondering how
the day is going to go um we do have a
number of debates so the quicker you
make your debates the quicker we can get
out of here this afternoon uh I'm
assuming we'll have to take a lunch
break we'll try and keep it at as short
a period as possible and uh we're going
by what the weather service says that
it's supposed to stop snowing around
4:00 we'll see how accurate they are
the house will attend to the consent
calendar are there any bills to be
removed from consent Mr Speaker on the
request to withdraw House Bill 476
removed by Representatives Heath Howard
Wade devise Sebert Wendy Thomas selig
bman senson parall and
Dy there any other bills that be remov
from
consent representative Osman moves a
consent calendar with a relevant
amendments as printed in today's house
record be adopted are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those opposed n the eyes have it and the
consent calendar is adopted under rules
of the house from the committee on
executive departments and administration
House Bill 216 FN is referred to
committee on finance from the committee
on Transportation House Bill 105 is
referred the committee on ways and
means the house will attend to a motion
to withdraw House Bill 476 f
relative to the restrictions on elective
abortion representative Howard Heath has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is not sufficiently seconded
this the motion before us is to withdraw
House Bill 476 FN relative to
restrictions on Ive abortion are you
ready for the
question was reest roll call was just
requested it was not sufficiently
seconded would you like a
division would you like a
division a division has been requested
members take your
seats turn on your voting
stations make sure everybody turns on
your voting stations e
for
C
were not there were not in the emails
that I received
want motion
all right the motion before us is to
withdraw our house bill
476 this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative Howard for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
HB 476 should not be tabled Sor I excuse
me I if I if I know that over 12,000
people testified in opposition and over
1,000 people in support of HP 476 if I
know that the withdrawal motion would
fulfill the uh request of the sponsor
and if I know that HB 476 should be
withdrawn please press the green button
thank you
chair recognizes representative Pentel
for a parliamentary
[Applause]
inquiry Mr
Speaker if I know that abortion
facilities in New Hampshire are
unlicensed and uninspected would I press
green if I know that this bill has the
capability of an allowing an abortionist
to open a facility in a basement and
perform undocumented unsterile abortions
with no recourse for Vic
victims if I know that this bill could
allow for coerced abortions to go
unpunished if I know that this bill has
the potential to harm
women particularly in situations of
human trafficking and if I know that
this bill is the very definition of
inexpedient to legislate would I now
vote
green the motion before us is to
withdraw House Bill 476
this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
representative
Bale all members president had an
opportunity to vote also attendance
state of the
vote 335 voting yay 18 voting nay bill
was
withdrawn house will now attend to the
regular
calendar for what reason does a member
rise Mr Speaker I move to reconsider the
vote on House Bill 476 and I request a
roll call
vote the motion is to Recon consider the
vote on House Bill 476 and a roll call
has been requested is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your seats
this isn't this isn't debatable is it
this isn't debatable
a motion itself is the underlying bill
is the motion before us is
reconsideration on House Bill
476 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you oppose you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent bigp
all members president had an opportunity
to vote how attend to stay the
vote 15 voting a 340 voting a
reconsideration
fails we have house
on the amend speak
and we on criminal justice and Public
Safety to which was referred House Bill
511 FN an act relative to cooperation
with Federal immigration authorities
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment recommendation
to bill pass with Amendment s of Terry
Roy for the committee the amendment is
Hest and there is a request for a
division on the amendment members take
your seats
clear that's
all right the motion before us is on the
amendment say division vote the
amendment is 0079 H printed in house
record 10 page 33 through
35 this is a division
vote if if you're in favor you'll press
the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds repres
[Music]
represent
Freeman representative you got to give
me a thumbs up or thumbs
down represent Marco
represent Marco thank
you represent Perez
all memb present had an opportunity to
vote house will attend to state to the
vote 356 voting
yay zero voting
nay the motion before us now
is ought to
pass on House Bill 511
is it
sufficient it is okay ask okay
representative Sweeney has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote
this is the
motion the am
the motion before is ought to pass with
Amendment this is going to be a roll
call vote chair recognizes
representative Osborne for a
parliamentary
inquiry representative Osborne waves it
so the motion before us is ought to pass
with Amendment this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button if you oppos you press a red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds for
[Music]
represent
Marco representative Edwards Mooney and
Warden
represent
TZ thank
you all members present had an
opportunity to vote how will attend to
state to the
vote 351 voting aay six voting nay
motion is adopted it's referred to
finance and this is referred to finance
majority committee on education policy
and administration to which was referred
H Bill 71 FN act prohibiting the use of
the facilities of a public elementary
school a public secondary school or an
institution of higher education to
provide shelter for aliens who have not
been admitted to into the United States
and consider the same report the same of
the recommendation the bill ought to
pass sen Brian n do for the majority of
the committee chair recognizer
representative B
bony thank you Mr
Speaker I rise today in opposition to
hp71 this bill would effectively ban
public schools from offering shelter
to undocumented people by threatening to
withhold State financial assistance to
those schools that do the stated purpose
of this legislation is to ensure that
our students are kept safe and will not
be subjected to remote learning in the
future however there is no exception
that schools May provide shelter in
times of need when the buildings are
empty and not being used for student
program programming such as during
vacation and summer
breaks this is an attempt to undermine
local
control as it is the responsibility of
the community to determine the usage of
the buildings they own and provide for
the safety and education of students in
their public school
system this bill is unnecessary and
attempts to solve a problem in our state
that does not exist it mirrors language
of the failed 2023 Federal schools not
shelters act currently New Hampshire is
not dealing with a massive influx of
undocumented people who need Emergency
Shelters according to the New
Hampshire's Department of Health and
Human Services this legislation could be
in direct conflict with current federal
guidance on providing shelter as well as
with Federal funding and Grant
obligations
the department could potentially lose 12
to18 million of federal funds per year
from the office of refugee resettlement
and the Department of Housing and Urban
Development the governor has warned that
revenues are down and we expect no
budget surplus to make up the difference
this loss of federal dollars could lead
to additional tax increases on our local
communities to to compensate for the
loss of federal
revenue finally this bill promotes
divisiveness perpetuating a national
narrative that all people without
documentation are dangerous and
diseased it will send a chill to
Immigrant and refugees families living
in our state and discourage people of
other nationalities and races from
studying at our College and universities
for fear that they will be targeted as
undocumented HB 71 does nothing to
improve students safety or education and
will jeopardize millions of dollars that
contribute to our state revenues I urge
you to vote no on the motion of OTP so
that a new motion may be made and Mr
Speaker I ask for a division
vote J recognize Harvey
bolia thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
passing this bill will ensure that our
schools remain dedicated to their
primary purpose providing a safe and
focused environment for our children's
education how the bill prioritizes the
use of school for Education rather than
for shelters for other populations here
are three things driving this
legislation the debilitating school
closures from the cover years our
closeness to Boston and the use of the
Logan airport for 6 months as a migrant
shelter and the use of a Brooklyn school
for the same our students and parents
deserve a learning environment free of
interruptions last this bill has carve
outs for emergency situations and it
doesn't have any effect on our revenues
thank you Mr
Speaker representative Sweeny has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats e
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 71 this is a roll call vote
chair recognized representative hall for
a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
Banning the use of public schools and
higher education institutions from being
used to shelter under documented persons
even when the buildings are empty for
extended periods of time demonstrates a
lack of basic
humanity and furthermore if I know that
hp71 interferes with local government's
ability to effectively govern and make
decisions about their own buildings and
finally if I know that it is estimated
that this legislation would result in
loss of 12 to18 million a year in
federal funding resulting in a downshift
downshift to local taxpayers but now now
press the red button so that another no
motion can be made chair recognize for
sener Freeman for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that all of us are committed
to keeping our school age children
teachers and support staff safe while
they are in our public schools and if I
further note that many unvetted
individuals have been allowed to cross
our orders over the past 3 years I would
then implore all of you and all of us to
protect our children and vote green on
this Common Sense piece of
legislation motion before us is ought to
pass on House Bill 71 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
we're in the voting mode members stay
their
seats well members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state of the
vote you want1 voting a 146 voting a
motion is adopted and this is on this is
being referred to
finance okay thank you so I freaking
pushed it because I'm the only one year
and I didn't want to anything
up committee on education policy
Administration to which was referred
House Bill 129 FN relative the
definition of the term evidence-based
within public education considered the
same report the same with the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
representative Margaret dry for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate
representative laurine seelig for the
minority of the committee chair
recognizes representative
SE thank you Mr Speaker and good morning
there are a number of reasons why HB 129
poses significant problems and has made
major gaps the bill says all methods of
delivering public education shall be
evidence-based this is unworkably Broad
when I was teaching I did my best to
meet the needs of all of my students I
tried all sorts of methods to keep them
engaged and learning sometimes pivoting
in the moment based on what was
happening in the class and learning for
myself what was working and what wasn't
on top of the prep work teachers are
already doing this bill would apparently
require them to do additional research
to find reproducible studies that have
been uh already completed to validate
these methods certified Educators
already attend teacher training programs
and teach and take continuing education
classes throughout their careers to
learn new and developing methods this
bill does not support that growth
additionally this bill further erodes
local control and creates a situation of
micromanagement of public school
teachers by the legislature while not
requiring any evaluation or criteria for
any private or Charter
schools finally and probably most
significantly in addition to the points
made in this week's calendar I would
like to point out that it is estimated
this bill would cost an additional
$118,000 in fiscal year
2026 increasing to
$127,000 in fiscal year 2028 for an
additional position within the
Department of Education it is also
estimated that the bill will increase
cost to local school districts to review
current procedures and implement the
requirements of this bill in a year
where we've already been told to expect
major Financial cuts to program
Statewide why would we choose to support
a bill that creates additional unfunded
mandates while creating more challenges
for our classroom teachers I urge you to
vote no on OTP so another motion could
be made and Mr Speaker I request a
division
vote J recognize ribson of dry
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker
evidence-based is used to describe
practices and everything from nursing
and health care to management and
research this bill proposes defining the
term evidence-based in public
education evidence-based in education
means teaching methods or techniques
that are reproducible in multiple
well-defined studies and able to be
independently
confirmed any use of this term and
Communications by the department of Ed
or local school districts has to conform
to this
definition this bill is about teaching
techniques not subject material it's
about how things are taught not what is
taught it's about material that is scien
driven not socially determined it's
about objective data not subjective data
or subjective
surveys it's about it's adopted at the
department or Schoolboard level not at
the classroom teacher level this bill
only applies to institutions like the
Department of Education or the local
school districts when they are adopting
teaching methods it doesn't dictate what
specific teaching methods are adopted
but only requires that consideration be
limited to those methods that have
demonstrated
Effectiveness in studies this
requirement does not apply to curriculum
nor does it place any burden on
classroom teachers who are purposely
Exempted and given a free
hand evidence-based is a powerful phrase
let's make sure that we understand what
it means and what we are saying when we
use it I ask you to support House Bill
129 thank you
s dry is requested a division this will
be a division vote members take your
seats
the motion before us is aut to pass on
House Bill 129 this is a division vote
chair recognized representative Cornell
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that house bill 129 takes away the
flexibility of an educator in their
classroom and does limit the
instructional choices that are needed to
meet the diverse needs of students in a
classroom and if I know that this bill
takes away our cherished local control
and if I know that this unfunded mandate
downshifts even more costs to local
taxpayers who are already paying large
property taxes would I now push the red
button to defeat the out to pass motion
thank
you J recognize representative Terry for
a parliamentary and
G thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that evidence-based in education
means teaching methods or techniques
that are reproducible in multiple
well-defined studies and able to be
independently
confirmed and if I know that teachers
will be assisted and students
benefit from utilizing these methods and
techniques that have proven to be the
current gold standard in the field of
education and if I know that we want New
Hampshire to be not only first in the
nation for our presidential primary but
also and even more importantly first in
the nation for
education then Mr Speaker wouldn't I
push the green button to do my part in
moving hp29 forward in pursuit of its
enactment into
law the motion before us is the majority
committee report of autop pass on House
Bill 129 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed to press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
represent pza
[Music]
while members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 203 voting aay 155 voting aay the
motion is
adopted and this also goes to finance
committee on Election law to which was
referred House Bill 67 FNA an act
relative to agreements with the
Secretary of State for the use of
accessible voting systems having
considered the same report the same with
a recommendation that the bill ought to
pass sen Robert warry for the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those oppose nay the
eyes have it the motion is is adopted
and this is on its way to finance
still and representative jav bolia
declared a conflict and did not
participate in the vote
the majority of committee on Election
lot to which was referred House Bill 340
FN an act relative through the election
hearing by public employees having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment the amendment is 0029 H
printed in house record 10 pages 32
through 33 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say I
oppos nay the eyes have it the amendment
is adopted read second reading open for
further Amendment representative Barry
office floor Amendment
0274 H it's in your seat
pockets are you ready for the question
on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppos nay the eyes have it and the
amendment is adopted the motion before
it's now is ought to pass as Amendment
chair recognized representative
Mirad Pi speech speech thank
you thank you very much Mr Speaker
um this bill uh would uh expand the
definition of what counts as
electioneering to include actions done
by public employees on the
job that unintentionally
have the effect of
influencing the way voters vote on
candidates or
measures and uh and and my concern is
that that idea of of including actions
that unintentionally influence voters is
over Brad and that there are a number of
things that public employees do in the
ordinary course of their jobs that might
have the effect of influencing the way
voters vote even though those public
employees don't intend what they do to
have that effect for instance a Public
Employee might share with the public
information about the condition of roads
and bridges in New Hampshire and a
member of the public learning about the
condition of roads and bridges might use
that information to influence the way
they vote the Public Employee can't
control how that's done information good
accurate information that public
employees share with citizens about
public things will influence the way
attentive citizens vote and public
employees can't control that but that
kind of action would be encompassed as
electioneering would be classified as
electioneering because of the over broad
way in which this otherwise
well-intentioned and salutary
Bill defines electioneering and for that
reason I would encourage us to defeat
the uh to pass motion so that we could
work more on this bill chair recognize
representive
Barry thank you and obviously I disagree
with the uh statement from the member of
the minority uh I I don't believe that
this bill would cover uh what he just
referenced uh this bill is designed to
do what the statute was originally
supposed to do which is stop public
employees from using their position and
government taxpayer funded resources
from putting their fingers on the scale
of of Elections and measures and I'll
give you two examples we had an issue in
amher with their SAU where three days
they sent it out on a Friday for filming
on a Monday in a public school they said
to parents hey on Monday we're bringing
a camera crew through uh we're going to
film the school um and oh by the way
your kids might be in that video um
we're also going to do interviews with
staff um and we're going to put they're
going to put together this video about
the school and what they didn't say was
that for the the previous three town
elections there had been a Warren
article about spending on the school
infrastructure so they were putting
their finger they were allowing a camera
to come through and film children so
that they could put their finger on the
scale of an outcome of a measure in the
town that I represent in gtown the
library put forward an overtly biased
survey that was found that was crafted
we found out through a right to no
request by by the employees eight out of
the 12 questions came from town
employees and the questions might as
well have read why are Republicans bad
and Democrats good and then the doj for
some reason said oh well you have an
opportunity to refute the
question the statute was designed to be
broad electioneering by public employees
is the only section of election law
currently with its own definition of
electioneering it was designed by this
body and by the way a member of the
other party was designed by this body to
be intentionally broad so that public
employees are not putting their fingers
on the scale and the reason you have to
have broad language is because when you
start talking about intent it is almost
impossible in a court of law to prove
intent the purpose of it being overly
broad is to go to what this body
originally enacted it is supposed to be
broad public employees should not be
using their position and their taxpayer
funded resources to change the outcome
of an
election the motion before us is
majority committee report of a to pass
as amended are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose
nay the eyes haven't and the motion is
adopted
second first
am majority committee on housing to
which was referred House Bill 60 an act
relative to determination of tendency at
the expiration of tency or a leas term
we consider the same report the same
with the recommendation to Bill ought to
pass
representative dick Laxon for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate sen of David
pagee for the minority of the
committee we have a number of amendments
here representative Reed offers floor
Amendment 02
54 it's in your seat pockets and the
chair recognizes representative Reed
thank you Mr
Speaker and uh in advance I'm going to
request a division on this to make sure
we don't
forget um I want to talk about what hb60
seeks to do and how this amendment
ameliorates some of the weaknesses and
some of the problems in the underlying
Bill the stated intent of hb60 is to
solve the problem that landlords are
being forced to keep otherwise good
tenants who pay their rent on time and
abide by all of the terms of their lease
um to evict them because the idea is
that there's this P pandemic of
landlords that are just being forced to
keep these really good tenants but all
of the examples as to why a landlord
would want to evict an otherwise good
tenant that pays their rent on time and
abides by all the rules that were given
in the hearing all of those are already
already protected in law there are
already causes to evict the the examples
given where well what if I want to raise
the rent and rent it for more that's
already allowed after you reach the end
of your lease you can raise the rent
however much you like if they don't want
to pay it they have 30 days the landlord
can already legally evict if they need
to do remediation or major Renovations
the landlord can already evict if they
want to change the use of the property
like I don't want to this out anymore I
want to change it into something else or
I want to let my adult Child live in it
all of these things are already
protected so then this has been working
for decades and the question is why now
why now when people are experiencing the
most housing insecurity we've ever
experienced as a state and if those
reasons aren't the real reasons then
what are the real reasons could it be
that maybe the
landlord after renting to the tenant saw
the the tenant's bumper stickers and
didn't like them could it be that they
saw the tenant associating with a
boyfriend or girlfriend or friend that
they didn't like the look of could it be
that the
landlord maybe had a political
disagreement or a sports disagreement or
any kind of disagreement or
that they the lieutenant chose to have a
firearm or chose to use medical cannabis
and maybe the landlord didn't like that
or maybe they just didn't like the fact
that the tenant insisted that the
landlord do repairs that the tenant is
legally um entitled to have done
whatever these reasons are these are
personal reasons and not professional
business-like reasons which is why the
law is currently how it is this
amendment seeks to try to solve some of
the damage that this would do by doing
three things first of all it provides a
six-month grace period so you reach the
end of your lease you're good tenant you
can continue that month to month that we
have currently for 6 months before you
get the 60-day notice of eviction and it
is a notice of
eviction the second is that if you were
a good tenant you paid your rent you did
everything correctly and the only reason
that you're getting that 60-day notice
of eviction is because you lived long
enough to see the end of your lease then
the record of the eviction will be
sealed because good tenants who pay
their rent who do everything right
shouldn't have this on their record in a
situation where even the best of tenants
are having a hard time finding something
because there's nothing available and
the final thing that this does is the
New Hampshire Housing Finance Authority
has said that a 5% vacancy rate among
properties is what is needed for a even
remotely healthy Market a 5% so what
we're saying in this amendment is fine
you can do this no cause eviction with
the six-month grace period but only in a
market that's 5% or greater not when
people are already having a problem
finding a place to live so that would be
the trigger is the 5% vacancy over that
they can do it under that we're in a
crisis so I hope that you support the
amendment J recognized representative
Alexander thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker this amendment would add a
trigger to the law to only make it go
into effect when the R Rental vacancy is
5% or higher for a 12-month period this
amendment will add unnecessary
regulation for our housing providers and
this bill is introduced already provides
for more certainty in the housing market
and encourages communication between
housing providers and tenants I urge the
body vot to vote no thank
you representative Sweeny has requested
a roll call on the amendment is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats for
clear the motion before us is read floor
Amendment
0254 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Reed for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that we are in the worst housing crisis
this state has ever seen with the most
housing insecurity that this state has
ever seen with the highest rate of
increase in homelessness that any state
is seeing
at all and if I further know that
although I understand that landlords may
not want to keep tenants that they
personally dislike in uh housing for
year upon year upon year that this is
not the time in a
0.6% vacancy to make housing more
insecure for the people who have to work
in the state and finally if I know that
the bill with this amendment passing
would still allow those land Lords to
kick out tenants they don't like for
personal reasons but would say that
there would be a six-month grace period
that the record of eviction would be
sealed for good tenants and would only
go into effect if we finally get to that
5% we're supposed to be at would I now
press the green button and pass the
amendment to make this a much more
reasonable Bill J recognize
representative Alexander for a
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know this bill
is carefully drafted and adds certainly
certainty to a volatile and
unpredictable housing market for both
housing provider and tenants and if I
know this bill is a good bill as is and
no changes are needed would I then press
the red button thank you the motion
before us is the read floor Amendment
0254 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote representative you declared a
conflict that's
why if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state of the
vote 140 voting a 217 voting aay the
amendment fails representative Schmidt
and representative Pat long declared a
conflict and did not participate in the
vote bills on second reading open to
further Amendment representative page
office floor Amendment
and the chair the chair recognizes
representative Paige
thank you Mr
Speaker like many of us in this citizen
legislature I wear a lot of
hats first and foremost I'm the proud
dad of two amazing kids I'm a
businessman I volunteer in my community
and I'm also a housing
provider I'm a small mom and popop
landlord
just like the folks this bill is meant
to
protect as I offer this amendment I want
to be
clear I understand the challenges that
this bill is trying to
address I've dealt with tough tenant
situations and I know how difficult the
eviction process can be for small
landlords these are legitimate issues
and I agree they deserve our attention
as a
body but I also have another ha that I
wear which is being a good
neighbor and as a good neighbor I have
to say without this amendment this bill
would do more harm than good and at the
worst possible
time let me share two numbers that
explain why this amendment is so
important in my
opinion
0.8% that's New Hampshire's current
rental vacancy rate 0.8%
and
52% that's how much homelessness
increased in our state from 2022 to 2023
and it's the highest jump in the entire
nation if we pass this bill without this
amendment families who get evicted For
No Good
Reason will quite simply have nowhere to
go that's the bottom
line virtually every family evicted
under this bill without this amendment
will experience some period of
homelessness and seniors and people with
disabilities will be particularly at
risk with this amendment what I hope I'm
offering is a reasonable middle
ground it simply ensures that the no
fault evictions this bill creates won't
take effect until that rental vacancy
rate reaches
2.5% and to be clear that's that's still
only halfway that's halfway to what
economists would consider a balanced
Market this way when good tenants are
forced out they'll at least have a fair
shot at finding another place to
live so I understand and I'm sympathetic
to the goals of the the underlying bill
but I also believe that folks who have
done absolutely nothing wrong deserve a
fighting chance to stay
housed especially at this moment where
we have the fastest growing ranks of
homeless people in the
country thank you Mr Speaker and I
request a division
vote chair recognized representative Al
Alexander thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker this amendment would add a TR
Tri to this law to only go into effect
when the R Rental vacancy rate is 2.5%
or higher for a 12-month period this
amendment would add unnecessary
regulation for our housing providers
this bill is introduced already provides
for more certainty in the housing market
and encourages communication between
housing providers and tenants please
vote no thank
you representative Sweeny has requested
a roll call on this amendment is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call on the
Amendment members take your seats
yes
the motion before us is the page floor
Amendment
0251 this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative hagner for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that without this amendment this bill
could result in UNH housing families in
our districts for No Just Cause And if I
want to support our housing part
providers but believe that we need to do
so in a responsible Manner and improve
the balance of the demand and supply
side of the market and if I know that by
passing this amendment we could Forge a
reasonable middle path to support the
reform of our eviction law while keeping
good tenants in their homes during a
housing crisis if I know all of this Mr
Speaker would I now press the green
button chair recognize representative
Alexander for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know this bill is carefully drafted and
adds certainty to a volatile and
predictable housing market for both
housing provider and tenants if I know
this bill is a good bill as is and no
changes are needed would I then press
the red button thank you
motion before us is the page floor
Amendment
0251 this is
a roll call vote and uh if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you oppose you press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative
Raymond represent Malone
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 145 voting aay 212 voting aay the
amendment fails representative Schmidt
in Pat long recused himself from the
vote for conflict of interest we are now
on to UT to pass on the original vote on
the original motion and the chair
recognizes representative David
pagee thank you Mr
Speaker when this bill
passes good people are going to be
forced out of their homes for no good
reason people who have always paid on
time and followed the rules people who
have lived in the same spot for decades
on a month-to-month lease suddenly
learning their have 60 days to rearrange
their entire
life I understand the struggles of
landlords trying to navigate New
Hampshire's eviction process but I would
ask my colleagues today to reject the
false premise that this bill is the only
answer to that problem or even a good
answer to that
problem this bill goes too far leaving
every tenant in New Hampshire vulnerable
to losing their home for no reason at
all
no fault eviction would also make it
infinitely harder for tenants who
believe they are being kicked out for
retaliatory or discriminatory reasons to
prove that as one lawyer shared in our
hearing her advice to her clients should
this bill pass would basically be tough
luck tough luck if you suspect your new
landlord just doesn't like you because
of the color of your skin or who you
love tough
luck tough luck if you complained about
the Heat and suspect
retaliation regardless of the
reason the Ripple effects of eviction
are
devastating kids lose stability in
school workers struggle to keep their
jobs and businesses struggle to keep
their
workforces towns already strapped for
cash are left footing the bill for
emergency housing and services and as
the state local welfare administrators
Association testified in committee when
we see this bill pass we will see
increased case loads and increased
costs as I noted in my prior speech
homelessness in New Hampshire jumped
52% but this isn't just a statistic it's
real people it's real people losing
their homes their security and their
sense of belonging and
Community it sounds very tidy
when you say a contract is a contract
and I get the appeal of that argument
but let's take a second to really ground
truth the stakes of the
bill the lived reality we'll experience
if this bill
passes if this bill passes another mom
and her kids will be living out of their
car if this bill passes another
displaced senior will be pitching their
tent out in the woods and I would wager
that some version of this
will play across all of our
districts I urge you to join me in uh
voting against OTP thank you chair
recognize representative
Alexander thank you Mr Speaker um hp60
is a bill that addresses termination of
tency this has nothing to do with
evictions um this has to do with
terminating a contract when a contract's
over there's a conversation about
renewing the contract it's basic
contract law so we're just keep we're
just updating in it to all the other
contract law in the state making sure
it's consistent when something expires
both parties come together and they have
a new contract they hash it out and
figure out what's moving forward there's
nothing wrong with this this is nothing
about evictions it's about renewing an
original contract
um and it also on top of that adds a
60-day notice so even if the contract's
about to expire the housing provider can
say hey your contract's expiring I don't
want to renew the contract and you have
to notice them within 60 days so would
do I think that's perfect no I'd say 30
days is great or or something less than
that because I think at the end of the
day it's your property you should do
what you want with it so um with that I
think the bill is good and you should
vote off to pass thank
you repr of Granger has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats for
the motion before us is aut the majority
committee report of autop pass and House
Bill 60 this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative
Gibbs for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that hb60 will cause good
tenants to lose their housing even
though they have always paid their rent
on time and have never caused any
problems and will cause some of these
good tenants to be put out on the street
through no fault of their own and
further increasing New Hampshire's
already large homeless population would
I now press the red button to vote no
thank you chair recognize representative
Duman for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that a legal contract requires
both a start date and an end date if I
know that clear expectations on both
sides creates a successful relationship
and if I know that this will add
increased certainty in an unusually
exacerbated rental market then would I
push green
button motion before us is a majority
committee report of a to pass anoun Bill
60 this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppos you press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote I'll attend to stay the
vote 217 voting yay 139 voting nay
motion passes
and representative Smidt and
representative Pat long declared a
conflict of interest and did not
vote committee on housing to which was
referred House Bill 399 an act
establishing a commission to study the
New Hampshire zoning enabling act
considered this the same report the same
with the following Amendment and
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment sen of David page
for the committee the amendment is 0023
H printed in house record 10 page 33 are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is ought to pass with Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I oppose nay the eyes
have it and the committee report is
adopted
majority of committee on housing to
which was referred House Bill 444 act
relative to a tenants right to
notification prior to the seale of a
multif family home considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative dick Thaxton
for the majority of the
committee minority of committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill are to pass
with Amendment Matthew Hicks from the
minority of the
committee chair recognizes
representative
Hicks thank you Mr Speaker colleagues I
Rise before you today to vote against
the itl motion for House Bill
444 anyone who has done this work those
are a few perfect bills and I'll accept
that this is not yet a perfect
bill in the education
field we use the Expression not yet to
help students understand that work is
needed to
improve not yet communicates that with
effort Improvement is possible and that
putting in
work they will grow as Learners the
alternative message is that we don't
believe in their ability to grow or to
improve the intent of House Bill 444 is
to help renters be aware of the S the
sale of their housing and even allow for
the possibility are purchasing their
housing thus increasing home ownership
and helping people to live more
financially secure
lives recognizing that home ownership
the home ownership part of this bill was
problematic to summon the housing
committee I urge you to focus on the
notification part of this bill instead
if a landlord provides notification on
the sale of the property it allows
renters to decide whether they are going
to begin looking for new housing or just
stay put we have heard many times that
when a rental property is sold it is
typical for rents to increase often
substantially and often Out Of
Reach it is also typical for renters to
be told only after the sale of a
property providing them no notice that
their lives are about to be thrown into
potential
upheaval I joined the housing Comm
wanting to work on bills and I again say
to do the
work support um supporting an itl motion
on this right means that we will are not
willing to work on this bill it sends a
message to our constituents that we
don't actually care about housing taking
the time to work on it sends a message
that we are listening that we're trying
that we're working for them and most
importantly that we care about them a
vote to itl this bill sends the wrong
message please vote no on this Mo motion
so an amendment can be offered that
simplifies the bill and helps Grant it
sters a simple notification requirement
for landlords is not overly burdensome
and it provides more transparencies for
renters about the changes in their
housing thank
you Mr Speaker I ask for a division vote
chair recognize rexton
thank you Mr
Speaker HB 444 is an act relative to
attendant's right to notification prior
to the sale of multif Family
Properties but it's more than that it's
really a right of first
refusal the goal of the housing
Committee in light of the current
housing crisis in New Hampshire is to
stabilize the housing market by
increasing affordability and
availability
increased investment in rental
properties will be a requirement to
achieve these goals under any scenario
HB 444 achieves none of those goals and
in facts undermines them
all this bill requires the owner of
multif family Residential Properties to
provide net tenants with notice of the
property and an opportunity to make an
offer to purchase the property while
effectively barring all other
purchasers what if I want to sell the
property to my sister my son put it in a
trust leave it as part of my estate this
bill represents a significant impediment
to the free flow of Commerce and
transfer of real property it would be a
restraint on the sale of residential
property and would in all likelyhood
decrease the willingness of individuals
and entities to invest in Residential
Properties in New Hampshire it does not
significantly improve the situation of
tenants who are looking to own a
home further this bill repres presents
significant potential unintended
consequences related to both estate and
tax planning for individuals and
entities that currently own residential
Investments the bill is fundamentally
socialist in nature and undermines the
rights of individual property ownership
and the aspirational goals of the
majority of
Americans passage of this bill impedes
individuals and entities willingness to
invest in and maintain residential real
estate by eliminating or complicating
the real estate transaction with no
appreciable public benefit the bill in
its current form is recommended as itl
and I ask you to vote
itl representative Granger has requested
a roll call as that's sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats e
the motion before us a majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
444 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Hicks for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know this bill could help granted
state ERS have more options and control
over their housing if I also know that
too often renters face uncertain Futures
as properties are sold without notice
and rents increase Beyond reach if I
believe that we all came here to work
for our constituents and find solutions
for crises like we are facing in housing
and finally if I'm certain that killing
imperfect bills that have Merit without
putting in the work to improve them
sends a message that we do not care
about our neighbors then would I now
vote against the io motion and allow for
a reasonable amendment to this bill
chair recognizes Michael Aaron for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill requires the
owner of restricted multif family
residential property to provide tenants
with notice of sale for the property and
an opportunity to make an offer to
purchase that property and imposes a
60-day waiting period for the tenants to
respond and if I know that a property
owner needed to sell quickly due to
health or financial reasons the 60-day
requirement in this bill would stifle
real estate sales especially cash sales
which have a very quick turnaround and
if I know that this bill adds more
regulation and will exacerbate the
housing crisis rather than alleviate it
would I then press the green button to
concur with the housing committee's
recommendation of it
the motion before us is expedi the
majority committee report of in
expedient legisl on House Bill 444 this
say roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press a green button if you're
oppose or press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote also tend to stay to the
vote 213 voting a 144 voting a committee
report is
adopted majority of the committee on
housing to which was referred House Bill
623 FN act relative to prohibiting
corporations from purchasing single
family homes for a certain amount of
time having considered the same for the
same with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
pres a Brian Cole for the majority of
the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation the bill ought to
pass sen David pagee for the minority of
the committee for what reason does a
member
rise to make a motion State your motion
I would like to make a motion to table
HB
623 there's a proper motion sen Murray
REM moves the
table House Bill
623 representative Sweeney has requested
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call
vote okay
en Jo
the motion before us is to table House
Bill
623 chair recognize representative
Murray for a
parliamentary thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know that uh between the
year 2020 and 2021 corporate ownership
of single family housing raised by 80%
and by 10 to 15% every single year since
then and if I further knowe that a new
Hampshire one of the largest crises
facing us right now is housing and that
is causing us to lose young people from
the state and families and if I further
know that a floor amendment has been
drafted to this bill that will allow us
to come to consensus on how to move
forward on this issue but that uh
amendment was not able to be submitted
in time to be heard today would I then
vote green to table this bill so that
amendment can be heard at a later
time chair recognize representative
Alexander for mentary inquiring thank
you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I know this
bill is not a good bill in any form and
I would like to have a vote on the
underlying Bill to put it to bed would I
then press right on tabling thank
you the motion before us is a table
House Bill
623 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press a green button if
you're opposed you'll press a red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
representative love it
represent
morgon represent
Hill all members president had an
opportunity to vote alend to stay the
vote
149 voting nay 207 voting nay the motion
fails we're back to the original motion
of in majority expedient to legislate
the chair recognizes representative
Murray thank you Mr Speaker and my
honorable
colleagues uh HB 623 attempts to
accomplish one simple thing which is to
prevent corporations from outbidding
families who are trying to purchase a
home this is a severe problem impacting
our housing market here in New Hampshire
and it's something that I've personally
been impacted by a few years ago my
husband and I were told by our landlord
that he would be renovating our
apartment and we needed to move out back
when this was happening in 2021 and
still to this day rents in Manchester
are the same or more than the average
mortgage so we decided to take the leap
and look for a home in the city we had
always lived in together over the next
two months we viewed a number of homes
even venturing outside of Manchester
which was where we wanted to stay until
the very last offer we made on the very
last house we toured every single offer
we made we were out bid on not by other
young families but by corporations these
mostly out ofst State groups would come
in often without even looking at the
property and put forward offers that
were irresistible to the owners almost
always paying in cash the most
devastating home we lost out on the
corporation overbid Us by
$150,000 and then proceeded to reach out
to my husband and I to ask if we would
like to rent the property from them this
is not a unique story and this is not
only a New Hampshire problem over the
last decade the number of investors
purchasing homes has increased from 10
10 to 15% each year except for 2020 to
2021 which according to a study by red
fin saw an increase of over
80% when looking at the wall Street
companies buying up homes you have a
small list of corporations that have
shaped this growing Trend one of the
first corporations to make waves in this
market is Blackstone founded in 1985
Blackstone or Blackstone Group is an
alternative investment firm based out of
New York blackstone's total Capital as
of 2021 sat at 880 billion over a third
of which came from its real estate
department this trend accelerated during
covid-19 when low interest rates and
Rising real estate prices spurred into
investors to expand their portfolios by
2022 investors accounted for nearly 30%
of single family home sales up from an
average of 16% just three years earlier
in some cities institutional investors
account for a far higher share of these
single family
homes according to a 2022 report by
MetLife hedge funds market share of the
7.6 million single family rental homes
in the US is projected to balloon over
the next decade from 5% in 2022 to over
40% by
2030 as in my own experience because
investors are paying in cash they can
often easily beat out first-time home
buyers in New Hampshire a third of home
sales in 2023 were purchased in cash on
top of this once they buy the Homes
single family rental companies often
prove to be bad landlords a 2022 study
by federal lawmakers found that five
major rental companies hiked their fees
by 40% over a 3-year period and saw
their tenants fall behind in rent in
California the state's largest corporate
landlord Invitation Homes was forced to
pay $2 million in sanctions after the
State Attorney General found it was
charging tenants illegally High rates
research has also documented that
corporate landlords file more evictions
than smalltime landlords which can
permanently harm tenants ability to find
housing in the future this legislation
is not unique a similar bill was
introduced to this body last session and
Democrats in the US Senate and House
have also sponsored similar legislation
a Republicans bill in the Ohio State
Legislature aims to drive out these
institutional owners through heavy
taxation while lawmakers in Nebraska
Iowa New York Minnesota and North
Carolina are among those proposing
similar
laws Republican Governor Greg Abbott
addressed this issue recently stating
this corporate large-scale buying of
residential homes seems to be distorting
the market and making it harder for the
average Texan to purchase a home this
must be added to the legislative agenda
to protect Texas families the bottom
line is while this bill is far from
perfect it's undeniably true that
corporations are creating an artificial
barrier to home ownership for our
Granite State families we need to be
encouraging young people to make their
home and raise their families here not
allowing corporations to force our own
people out so they can increase their
investment
portfolios if we table this bill a floor
Amendment will be brought before the
body in next session to turn this
legislation into to a study committee so
we can find a way we can all agree on to
stop this hostile corporate takeover and
solve the housing crisis as granted
Staters so desperately have asked us to
do thank you Mr
Speaker and I request a division vote
chair recognize representative
Cole thank you Mr Speaker I rise today
in opposition of HB 623 FN an act that
would prohibit corporations and other
legal entities from purchasing single
family homes for 90
days while the intent of this
legislation may stem from legitimate
concerns the language in its current
form it's unworkable it's overly Broad
and it's
problematic this bill does not just
Target Corporations it encompasses all
non-natural persons including llc's and
nonprofits the sweeping definition
creates unintended consequences that
extend far beyond the Bill's stated
purpose it would slow property
transactions it would incentivize
sellers to wait 90 days to outwait the
90-day restriction period for po
potentially higher
offers this delay would create
additional barriers not just for
corporate buyers but for other buyers
trying to enter the housing
market furthermore the bill includes
penalties such as cheating property to
municipalities for violations
however lacks The Clarity on how the
process will be implemented or funded no
Appropriations have been made and
administrative burden was placed on this
mun and municipalities this will be an
unfunded
mandate some argue this bill addresses
the growing issue of corporate investors
dominating the housing
market pointing to antidotes and
National
reports let's focus on the
facts corporations only own 3% of the
housing market in the United States and
less than 1 half% in New Hampshire this
is not a widespread issue for this
state for these reasons I urge The Bu to
support the itl motion and I call for a
roll call
vote V Senate Sween has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats e
okay the motion before us majority
committee report of any speeding to
legisl and House Bill 623 this is a roll
call J recognizes represent Reed for
parliamentary thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that we
have reached the point where over a
third of single family rentals are
corporate owned not owned by small
landlords based in the state but owned
by large investment
firms and if I know that these large
investment firms they're not the
friendly
landlords that we think of in this state
but that they are actually driving the
increase in our unaffordability in this
state with this NeverEnding cycle of
buying properties well over market value
because then they can raise the rent
which increases the value and then they
buy another property for even more than
that driving our unaffordability
and if I know that the market the free
market Market in housing or anything
else only works when supply and demand
are both free to come and negotiate
unencumbered but then when you have
people who have to live in a place that
they are coming to that table with their
hands tied behind their back they can't
go homeless they have to accept whatever
they're being
given and lastly well second to last if
I Mr Speaker am really tired of the
sacred cow that has gone unchallenged
for decades that anything in the name of
greed is good even while our religions
our ethics our morals and our logic
dictate the exact
opposite and lastly Mr Speaker if I know
that if the itail is overturned there is
an amendment to just make this a study
committee because can't we at least
study this that's happening with the
corporate gobbling up of our single
family homes and driving up costs
then would I press the red
button and overturn the itl so that we
can at least study this chair recognize
repr bullier for parliamentary
inlo thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know this bill
interferes with a homeowner's right to
sell their home to a willing buyer on
mutually agreed terms and if I know this
bill would take private property away
from small investors who own their
property through llc's or even local
nonprofit organizations that offer their
own housing and if I know this bill
would require the Secretary of State to
establish an expensive and cumbersome
registration system that adds a new
layer of red tape to single family and
multif family housing development and if
I know that ultimately this socialist
bill would do nothing
to fix our housing shortage actually
make it worse by stifling investment in
new and renovative places for the people
of New Hampshire to live would I now
press the green button to support the
committee's majority report of
inexpedient to
legislate motion before us is the
majority committee report of inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill
623 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative
McGee represent
MC representative
cyber present
while members president had an
opportunity to vote household tend to
state to the
vote 216 voting yay 141 voting aay the
committee report is
adopted see not I believe a lot of you
will probably be going downstairs for
lunch we're going to take our lunch
right now and we'll come back at 1:00
and we still got 12 bills to go
through
1:00 I'll being in
recess
e
e e
members take your seats
got
so members take your seats
[Music]
house will come to
order chair recognizes a
clerk thank you Mr Speaker
from the chair and the committee of ways
and means pursuant to house rule 47f I
hereby wave House Bill 105 from the
committee on Ways and Means John
Janan committee on Judiciary to which
was for at House Bill 164 FN an act
relative to local records retention
having considered the same report the
same with a recommendation the bill
ought to pass Joe Alexander for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I oppose nay
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted and it's on its way to
finance de
on De the
majority committee on Municipal and
County government to which was referred
House Bill 78 an act requiring a person
to have a domicile in the district from
which they serve as County Commissioner
consider the same report the same with
the following Amendment and
recommendation of Bill a pass with
Amendment sen of Linda France for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate of Jim for
the minority of the
committee the amendment is
0348 printed in house record 10 pages
28 the chair recognizes representative
Horgan thank you thank you very much I'm
represent um so I'm uh speaking speak
against the amendment I have no issue
with the underlying Bill the original
version is introduced I think is good
but um so that's but we have to we have
to overturn the amendment to get to the
underlying bills so um up until well up
until 2022 straford County elected its
three County Commissioners from a single
at large district and they or perhaps I
should say we because I live in straford
County so we've been doing so for many
many years um what I've I've heard it
was since 186 five um and some people
think the switch to three districts was
a good idea some think it was a bad idea
I I'm not here to relitigate that issue
today although
there there will be a bill about that uh
coming up later in the session actually
the hearing is next week um anyway in
2024 we an ele we had our first County
Commissioner election with the three
districts um including a contested
primary on the Republican side in
District 3 so three County Commissioners
elected um two two new members a
longtime incumbent and so far in the
last month or two an office they seem to
be an excellent group so one of the two
new Commissioners does not live in the
district he represents now that may seem
a little weird but RSA 6559 the law
which sets the qualifications for County
Office says that's okay well at least
currently it says it's okay and that RSA
has been unchanged since it was created
in
and so what that law says and it's been
the same for uh all those 50 uh since
1979 it never been a problem says County
C officers currently quote must have a
domicile in the county for which he has
chosen um obviously at some point we
want update he to he or she or but
unquote and additionally in a list of
nine counties I counted them there are
nine which are not in any really
discernable order you must have a
domicile in your District so you know
it's
that's pretty simple I could probably
think of ways to make it simpler but
that's like simple and straightforward
and it it
works anyway for whatever reason to get
back to uh last year the previous
election the enabling legislation passed
in
20123 which created the three districts
which were voted on in
2024 did not change RSA
6559 and I I the member will suspend
yeah
yeah the member has a right to be heard
and it's getting awful noisy okay well
thank you member May I've dealt with
Worth's noise but um anyway so in 2023
for whatever reason when we created the
three County Commissioner districts and
made the other changes for some reason
they skipped over RSA
6559 and so as a result in straford
County we now have districts but you
don't have the live in your district and
as I said that seems weird but in voter
District 3 not the district I live in I
live in District Two but District 3 the
voters chose a person who lives in
District Two and um so they seem to be
happy with their with their choice I
think they made a good choice um anyway
I thought that admission was deliberate
but turn turned out um shortly after the
filing period in June 2024 that it fact
had been a mistake and there was a bit
of a Ruckus at the ballot law commission
but the law clearly said you know that
the law that straford County was not on
that list of count counties that if you
counted all the counties there were only
nine and straford County was the 10th
County so that's a little embarrassing
although I mean worked okay people at
District three have a competent County
Commissioner representing
them so anyway the bill is introduced
would have taken a rather logical and
simple approach probably about the
simplest approach possible by simply
adding and straford at the end of that
list of counties and so that list now
includes all 10 counties I count it
again yes there are there are 10
counties no counties are repeated it's
all 10 counties um it left the domicile
requirement in place and this seemed
like a very simple
solution the amendment changes rather
simple Doon RSA 659 with some very wordy
language which I think would have all
sorts of unintended consequences so
that's uh that's why and uh you can you
can see what the language is for
yourself um it's on in the calendar
actually in two places on the committee
report and also on the uh Amendment
which if I recall correctly is on page
um so regardless of how you feel about
the underlying bill so I I urge you to
uh reject the amendment and go back to
the original bill is introduced which in
my opinion is a much better solution to
it so I thank you for your
attention and I I would take any
questions if anyone had one but I don't
think anybody wants wants to ask them
but anyway thank you for your attention
and thank you Mr Speaker
chair recognize rep
power thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
support of amendment
0034 to House Bill
75 this simple and straightforward
Amendment does three things first it
clarifies the requirements for County
offices secondly it strengthens the
existence existing residency
requirements for County Commissioners
by clearly stating that a commissioner
must be an
inhabitant who resides actually and
permanently in the County District for
which they are elected to represent
lastly the amendment further makes it
clear than that an elected County
official shall cease to hold office if
they move out of the county or District
they represent for these reasons I urge
my fellow colleagues to support these
Common Sense
clarifications by voting yes on the
amendment and also yes on the otpa
motion thank you Mr
Speaker a division has been requested
this will be a division vote members
take your
seats for
the motion before us is amendment
0034 h this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're oppose you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
cyber while members pres had an
opportunity to vote house attend to stay
to the
vote 325 voting nay 30 voting
nay the amendment is adopted motion
before us now is majority committee
report of a to pass as amended on House
Bill 78 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I the eyes have
it the committee report is
adopted majority committee on Municipal
and County Government to which was
referred House Bill 110 an act
authorizing counties to establish
revolving fund accounts consider the
same report the same with the following
Amendment and recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with Amendment
presentative John McDonald for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate
representative Stephanie Run for the
minority of the committee
thank you Mr Speaker I rise today in
opposition to hb110 hb110 creates an
unnecessary revolving account we
acknowledge that budgeting for
representative we haven't done the
amendment yet oh
sorry the amendment is
0057 H printed in house record 10 pages
29 through 30 the vote are you ready for
the question on the amendment all those
in favor say I I those oppose nay the
eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted now I recognize representative
one thank you Mr Speaker appreciate that
so HB 110 creates an unnecessary
revolving account we acknowledge that
budgeting sa Safety Services is
difficult to predict we heard testimony
from a sheriff that they attempt to
budget for additional traffic detail by
including larger expense projections the
concern is that this raises taxes is
inaccurate because revenue from details
offsets expenses resulting in a net zero
impact on the budget if the department
is not making money on work detail they
should reassess the rates charged
establishing a revolving fund requires
seed money this would come from an
increase in taxes to establish the fund
the bill allows the fund to accumulate
from year to year with revenues
transferring to the general fund when
the revenues exceed the original balance
constant transfers between the revolving
fund and the general fund would
complicate financial management this
creates excess work duplicating existing
procedures at the end of the fiscal year
when excess Revenue would normally be
transferred to the general fund there is
also concern that tracking expenses such
as net vehicle maintenance equipment
wear and tear and insurance costs would
become more complex if these costs
remain in the general fund but revenues
are diverted it inflates the budget
without a clear offsetting Revenue
Source Revenue should not be realized at
the time of year end audit what are the
Alternatives if a department experience
is a busier than exper expected year
they can request an increase from the
delegation rather than relying on the
revolving fund the delegation could also
pass a resolution allowing the sheriff
to exceed the line item by a set amount
as long as the revenue covers additional
expenses as budget transfers and
resolutions would be reconciled each
year there there is already an existing
approach to solve the problem does not
add cost to the taxpayers in conclusion
hb110 is unnecessary and would create
additional challenges by for County
staff by increasing administrative
burdens without providing a real
solution existing budget processes
already allow counties to manage
Sheriff's Department detail work
effectively without recurring a separate
revolving fund and Mr Speaker I ask for
a division
vote chair recogniz uh representative
John
McDonald thank you Mr Speaker hb110 is
amended is a very simple Common Sense
enabling bill for our County government
it would allow by a vote of the county
delegation to establish a County public
safety revolving fund to support the
payment of County Employees within our
Sheriff's Office the revolving fund
would be used to pay work outside of the
ordinary daily duties of the deputies it
will be used for employee payment for
special events construction details and
other Public Safety purposes deemed
appropriate by the sheriff the amount of
the fund to start the public safety
evolving fund would be determined by the
delegation any Revenue received from the
extra activities or Services supported
by the fund would be used to replenish
the fund in the event of revolving fund
exceeds the original funding used to
establish the fund the excess money will
be deposited into the county general
fund um the county delegation can also
Place limitations on expenditures from
the public safety fund no money from the
fund may be used for anything the
delegation has specifically rejected and
also the county treasur will be the
custodian of the fund uh the folks
that'll make the decision to uh take
money of the fund will be the County
Commissioners in conclusion the majority
believes the public safety revolving
fund will be as successful as the
established Municipal revolving funds
that we have in our communities thank
you
motion before us majority committee
report of what pass as
amended are you ready for the
question oh I'm sorry I didn't hear that
division has been requested members take
your
seats e
C the motion before is a majority
committee report of Auto passes amended
on House Bill 110 chair recognized
representative Gerard for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
this bill appears to be unnecessary as
the issue it seeks to address could be
resolved through proper budgeting
without imposing additional cost to
taxpayers if I know implementing this
bill would require initial seed money
which would directly impact the county
budget through taxation I would have
serious concerns if I know this bill
creates lack of transparency and
accountability I would be deeply
concerned about the potential for
mismanagement given these factors would
I vote no and press the red button at
this time thank you chair recognized
representative John McDonald for
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know the public
safety revolving funds are extremely
successful in many New Hampshire
communities and municipalities further
Mr Speaker if I know the public safety
revolving Huns will save taxpayers money
lastly Mr Speaker if I know there are
sufficient safeguards in the bill
protecting the expent ages of these
funds I would push the green button
thank
you the motion before us a majority
committee report of water path as
amended on House Bill 110 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you press the red button voting stations
are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
har G
right all members present had
opportunity to vote house attend to stay
to the
vote 182 voting a 175 voting committee
reports
adoped majority committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred House Bill 95 FN act requiring
the New Hampshire Electric Co-op
regularly file a certificate of
deregulation with the Public Utilities
Commission having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpedient
to legislate Senor Janine n from the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Wendy Thomas from
the minority of the committee are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say
iose
nay you guys have it committee report is
adopted
majority committee on science technology
and energy to which was referred House
Bill 106 act establishing a commission
to determine the monetary costs of
climate
change damage to the state of New
Hampshire and the best means of
recouping such cost having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Doug Thomas for the majority of the
committee minority of the
committee having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass representative Tony
Kaplan for the minority of the committee
chair recogniz representative
Kaplan thank you Mr Speaker and uh hello
colleagues HB 106 is a very simple bill
there's been some misunderstandings
about it there's been the claim that it
intends to Target a particular class of
business which it does not that's not
how commissions work work HP 106 intends
to set up a a bipartisan commission to
made up of uh legislators
representatives of business and industry
department heads Etc to study two things
the financial cost of impending climate
damage on the state of New Hampshire and
number two the best way to pay for the
adaptation work that we need in order to
minimize the risk of our communities to
climate
damage so this bill is premised on the
warnings we've been receiving from the
science Community for decades now on the
risk of burning fossil fuels to our
climate the science is unequivocal and
the evidence points to these changes
which we can see with our own
eyes increased coastal flooding on our
Sea Coast shorter Winters impacting on
our tourism industry hotter Summers with
cyano bacteria
blooms with increased rain events
washing out our roads uh increased
tickborne mosquito born illnesses we all
know these things are happening and the
science is quite clear the more the
atmosphere warms the greater impact
these changes will
have for instance we know with great
certainty based on the science that
there will be an increase in extreme
weather events in the coming decades we
also know for certain that our
infrastructure is not in shape to handle
those stresses for instance in our in
our committee we heard from the
Department environmental service Dam
Bureau that our aging Dam infrastructure
uh needs $900 million in order to get
into shape that's almost a billion
dollars just for the dams so this is not
an irresponsible response that's try to
set up a committee to look at this issue
we know for instance that of the nine
planning authorities around the state
several are looking at climate change
and studying the ways to pay for the
adaptation and resilience work which
they have identified we know the
department of environmental service is
aware of this issue what is needed is
take a coordinated look at this issue
and that that's what this commission can
provide so why is this not a good idea
well you can doubt the need for a study
based on doubting the the changes that
are happening and that has to do with
some of the contrarian opinions that we
heard in our Committee hearing and that
by the way is the Playbook that the
fossil fuel industry has employed for
the last several decades to Forstall any
action that might hurt their business
model despite hearing from their own
scientists as early as 1970s that
burning their product would impact the
climate in dangerous ways they went on
to spread propaganda and bad science in
order to cast doubt and uh ensure that
nothing ever happened so for instance in
our committee we had a man come in
claimed he was a toxicologist stressed
his professional expertise several times
uh but one thing he said really caught
my ear and that's when he said it would
be futile that was the word he used it
would be futile to try to quantify the
impact of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere now if there's one thing I
know about science and scientists is
that they will quantify the kneecap on a
grasshopper for years and years that
they think it's going to add to the body
of knowledge so that was a red flag
right away and as far as carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere well that's something
I learned about in school it's called
the greenhouse effect it's what makes
life possible on the planet it's the
fact that yes carbon dioxide is a very
small infinitesimally small part of the
atmosphere but it's one of the few gases
that absorbs heat so all you need is
just a little bit and it keeps the heat
that wants to escape back to outer space
it keeps the heat inside the atmosphere
is what makes life possible problem is
we keep adding more and more carbon
dioxide so that warming effect is int is
increasing in intensity but uh so what
he was saying is you could call it
contrarian opinion but that would be a
generous assessment it's basically
crackpot science we had another
gentleman come in who uh much more a
personable very persu very persuasive
very well spoken gentleman remind me of
somebody else I know but that's all I'll
say about that um he took a page out of
the ipcc report which is good because
the ipcc report is the gold standard for
climate science and it's the the world's
top CL climate scien is appointed by the
respective governments they come
together they study the issue and they
issue a report every five years or so
latest one was 3,000 or so pages long he
had a a chart from page 2,000 or so and
uh it purported to show time of
emergence on climate risks I went look
time of emergence is a relatively new
branch of climate science that tries to
show when these climate risks emerge
from the natural variability problem is
the natural variability is measured by
historical data which is very lacking in
lots of parts of the world there's not a
lot of historical data in Africa or Asia
or Latin America so the level of
certainty around time of emergence is
very low and so that's what this chart
showed and so he said see the the ipcc
has very low level of certainty on these
climate risks which is exactly the
opposite conclusion that the entire
3,000 page report is intended to convey
so it was very cherry-picked very
selective very cynical yet it had its
effect the doubt was cast we heard in
our committee that hey you know up could
be down down could be up it could be
back it could be forth we don't know all
opinions are equally valid therefore the
proper course of action is to take no
action so and I and we we had a quote
from I think it was the poet TS Elliot
the famous uh climate poet TS Elliott
who said reality is very hard it's too
hard to discern for the ordinary human
being well I agree with that reality is
too hard to discern for Orin human
beings that's why we have the science
they are our eyes and ears and as
Leaders as policy makers we count on the
science we take the consensus opinion we
take the weight of the evidence and we
CH a path forward for our constituents
that's why these uh contrarian crackpot
opinions are no excuse and inaction is
not an
option this bill HB 106 is basically us
taking a walk to the top of a hill to
see what is coming if you don't want to
take a walk to the top of a hill I would
suggest you get out of the way and let
people who do want to lead do
so
so I would suggest that we vote red on
this itl and move up the hill to a
better motion thank you Mr Speaker and I
call for a roll call vote
please chair recognize from Doug
Thomas thank you Mr
Speaker uh Mr Speaker this bill is based
on a premise that is flawed and is under
dispute we did hear expert
testimony as to various reasons why um
climate change is still up for debate we
should not be putting we should not be
putting um speculative premises into
statute the house will be in
order but the real problem with this
bill because of the premise is a
commission in statute actually
blames a one class of of um business
fossil fuel companies for damages that
have yet to been that have have yet to
occur and a predicting of what they
might occur in in the
future and it says that these fossil
fuel companies will be will be charged
not if or what will be charged now you
can imagine the the potential lawsuits
involved with this bill company a says
wasn't my fossil fuel fumes that caused
this uh crop damage it was company C
over here the company C might say oh no
it wasn't mine mine didn't get over
there uh it must have been coming over
from Canada or maybe over from from New
York this opens up a lot of bad
litigation on
this and I'm going to end this by just
saying this because this bill if you
read it actually says
that fossil fuel companies are to blame
and will pay this bill almost puts just
about puts into question a
constitutional issue of guilty without
due process so I would rather not go
down that route I think this is a
dangerous Bill the way it's written
please vote green
itl representative Kaplan has requested
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your seat States
C
the motion before us majority committee
report of inexpedient to
legislate this is a roll call vote chair
recognizer absent of Kaplan for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill sets up a study
commission and in no way conveys any
language that targets any particular
business and that a study commission
works by consensus and collaboration and
hears from experts on any
issue before reaching any conclusion or
making any recommendations if I know
that not to prepare is to prepare to
fail and lastly Mr Speaker if I know
that 70% of Granite State voters want
their government that would be us to do
something about this issue which is upon
us what I now vote red Mr Speaker if I
know that suing big oil is very
expensive costing Millions of taxpayer
dollars and that previous attempts have
been
unsuccessful and if I further know that
the position of the current
Administration is drill baby drill then
would I now press the big green button
to let the federal government and other
states with deeper Pockets lead the way
thank
you the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inex Meed to legisl
on House Bill 106 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds e
[Music]
representa
Dolan representa
DOL Walmer president an opportunity to
vote also attend to state of the
vote 207 voting yay 149 voting a
committee report is adopted
she
majority committee on science technology
and energy to which was referred House
Bill 189 an act def finding clean energy
and the department of Energy's 10-year
State energy strategy to include new
technology smallscale nuclear energy
renewable energy and fuel diversity
removing references to the Energy
Efficiency and sustainable energy board
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with
Amendment pres of Doug Thomas for the
majority of the committee minority of
the
committee having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate is of C McGee from the
minority of the
committee the first the first committee
amendment is
015h printed in house record 10 pages
31 there is no debate on this amendment
all those in favor fa say
iose
nay the eyes have
it
representative McGee bills on second
reading open to further
Amendment representative McGee offers
floor Amendment
H and is recognized to uh
speak everybody following
uh good afternoon thank you Mr
Speaker okay let me try and explain this
one to you um HB 189 is essentially a
housekeeping Bill except for the changes
adopted by the amendment that we just
voted on um the amendment inserts a
definition of the words clean energy
into the statutory
construction that redefines a
well-defined term to include low
emissions sources
uh the bill started with a desire to
include nuclear power in the state
energy statutes and uh under the clean
energy definition that would be put into
the statutory language um no one on the
science technology and energy uh
committee argued that nuclear power
doesn't qualify as a clean energy source
when nuclear plants run they do not emit
pollutants or greenhouse gases and that
is the accept
definition of clean
energy but once we agreed that we should
Define the term in the broadest possible
sense rather than identifying individual
energy sources in the definition we went
off to lunch and it devolved into
Reinventing the wheel people started
word smithing so the definition that we
have now as I said includes low emitting
sources um we have a choice this morning
as to how we want to approach the
state's definition of clean energy you
can accept the amendment before you
which redefines the meaning of clean
energy to include sources that emit
pollutants and greenhouse gases when
they operate or you can review the
single sentence floor amendment in your
seat pockets that's
0246 H which is listed up here um which
uses the American Association for the
advancement of Sciences is definition of
clean
energy um the accepted meaning is clean
energy is an energy source that does not
release pollutants or greenhouse gases
during use it's clear it's simple and
it's widely
accepted I ask for your no vote on the
original well it's too late the that
ought to pass uh on the committee
Amendment already went through I ask
that you uh pass this amendment so that
we can send an accurate definition
across the wall rather than having them
try to repair our inaccurate definition
um and I ask that we have a roll call
vote on that we should be able to send
them a very simple simple Bill thank
you representative V is recognized speak
against the floor
Amendment colleagues I urge you to vote
against this floor Amendment for two
reasons
number one the original Bill
explicitly added nuclear to the
definition of clean energy this
amendment makes no mention of nuclear it
doesn't exclude nuclear but we think
it's important to explicitly include
nuclear in the definition of clean
energy the other reason to oppose this
amendment is in the committee Amendment
we very consciously and purposefully
chose the term low
emitting as opposed to non-emitting
because we didn't want to exclude
certain kinds of renewable energy for
example
windmills large windmills wind
turbines frequently use a diesel motor
to start them because the blades are so
heavy that the wind can't start them on
its own so you have to have a diesel
motor to start those turbines in
addition those turbines if they're in a
cold weather environment like New
Hampshire they need a source of
heat so the diesel motor in the wind
turbine can provide that source of heat
but it is an
emitting
Technologies but it's a low emitting
technology and the windmill is mostly a
renewable non emitting
technology in addition to that some uh
effort is being made to to
create hydrogen as a form of
energy it's not really but that's a
subject for another
day but the techniques used to create
hydrogen are
frequently either using natural gas or
using Renewables like solar to create
hydrogen well if you use natural gas
that's a an emitting source so in this
definition in this
amendment of non-emitting
of clean energy
a emitting Source like natural gas to
create hydrogen would mean that hydrogen
is not clean energy so for those reasons
we think this amendment is not a good
one and we would urge you to vote uh red
on the adoption of this amendment thank
you does the member yield for a
question
yes representative Harrington you may
inquire thank you Mr speaker thank you
taking my question uh representative
would you agree that this amendment as
written would specifically exclude
nuclear power because in order to
operate a nuclear power plant must run
its diesel generators every 30 days is a
condition for continued operation those
are polluting they pollute obviously
they would be considered low polluting
because they don't run that often but
under this amendment no nuclear power
plant uh in New Hampshire or basically
any place else would qualify as clean
energy
yes I would agree to that and it falls
under the same has the same problem as
the wind turbines so thank you for
that representative MC McGee requested a
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is officially seconded this
will be a roll call vote members take
your
seats e
the the questions on the adoption of
floor Amendment
0246 H this is a roll call
vote representative McGee is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker um while I respect my colleague
and his position uh as spoke against uh
the floor Amendment it is actually as
simple as I explained
it if I
know thank you colleagues it's I'm
tired if I know that um that the
definition is the only piece of this
bill that is in question and if the
accepted definition if I know that the
accepted definition from the American
Association for the the advancement of
Sciences has defined clean energy as
energy sources that do not release
pollutants and greenhouse gases during
use and that is what is used in the
amendment then would I now press the
green button to pass the amendment so
that we can send a clean definition of
clean energy over to the other side of
the wall thank
you representative V is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that this
amend M would exclude nuclear energy
from the definition of clean energy
which is the exact opposite of what this
bill was intended to do when I now press
the red button to defeat this floor
Amendment thank
you the questions on the adoption of
amendment 0246 H this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor of adopting the
amendment press the green button opposed
press the red voting stations are open
for 30
seconds e
[Music]
repres
Wilson represent Wilson up or down
please have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 150 in the affirmative 204 and the
negative the amendment fails
the motion now is uh to pass as amended
on House Bill
189 representative McGee is recognized
speak against the
motion thank you Mr
Speaker uh as I as I mentioned
colleagues um the definition that's
currently in uh hb89 as amended does
include
non uh non-clean sources and um and why
would we need the term clean energy if
we're going to include sources that do
not meet that definition I would ask
that you vote against the
OTA um and I would hope that if this
definition is going to be adopted that
we we are able to come to an agreement
on our committee and put it somewhere
else we have plenty of bills pending
that we could amend this to
but um I just don't want to see us
passing a definition that is really
non-standard and that shouldn't be in
our statutory construction thank
you representative Thomas has recognized
to speak in support of the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker simple definition nuclear
should be included in clean energy the E
the EU has it a lot of US states have it
Colorado and New York are are passing a
bill similar uh this year please vote
green on otaa thank
you the motion is off to pass as amended
on House Bill 189 representative McGee
has requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your seats
is
clear
the questions on the committee report of
about to passes Amendment on House Bill
189 and this is a roll call vote
representative McGee is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that there is nothing
about the definition of clean energy
that excludes nuclear power and I would
like people to understand that there is
no attempt to exclude nuclear power from
clean energy and if I know that this
bill creat creates a definition of clean
energy that is non accepted in the World
At Large and there is no reason for New
Hampshire to have its own specific
definition that was designed at lunch by
people who have an opinion when there is
an accepted definition then would I now
press
the red button thank
you representative Bernard is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
clean energy is reasonably and fairly
defined as low greenhouse gas emitting
sources including nuclear and Renewables
and if I know it is appropriate that
clean up our rsas of defunct
organizations reference therein would I
press the green button to pass this
bill the questions on the majority
committee report of oop pass is amended
on House Bill 189 and this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button opposed press the red
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
represent
Bernard have all members present and an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 206 in the affirmative 148 and the
negative the committee reports adopted
for what reason does a member rise I
Rise to make a motion to allow the
gentlemen to remove their jackets except
when speaking at the well several are
very
hot I don't know why that's funny but
repres of couta moves a gentlemen May
remove their coats except when speaking
at the well are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I any
oppos
nay the eyes have it and the motion's
adopted
the majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which is
referred House Bill 306 an act
establishing a commission to study the
short and long-term impacts of pending
National and Regional carbon pricing
mechanisms on New Hampshire's citizens
businesses institutions and environment
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative Jan nder for
the majority of the committee the
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
you pass representative Wendy Thomas
from the minority of the
committee for what reason does the
member rise thank you Mr Speaker move to
lay HB 306 on the table representative
Osborne moves to lay House Bill 306 on
the table are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose nay no the eyes have it House
Bill 306 is laid on the table
the majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred House Bill 526 FN an act
establishing a climate change and damage
division in the Department of
Environmental Services having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Janine ner for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative Wendy
Thomas for the minority of the committee
for what reason does the member rise
thank you Mr Speaker move to lay HB 526
on the table representative Osborne
moves at House Bill 526 be laid on the
table for what reason does the member
Rise um I would like to present a pi on
this I'm sorry I would like to present a
pi on this motion you want a division no
I'd like a roll call please represent
Thomas request representative Thomas
requests a roll call on the motion to L
House Bill 526 on the table that is
sufficiently seconded members take their
seats e
the question is whether to lay House
Bill 526 on the table and this is a roll
call
vote representative Bernard is
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry if I know we don't need to spend
nearly a million dollars a year
establishing a new agency to Divine the
difference between weather events and
climate
change would I vote green on this
tabling
motion representative Thomas recognized
for parliamentary inquiry Wendy
Thomas uh Mr Speaker if I know that
house bill 526 addresses a very
important topic that impacts the
economic environmental and business
impact on climate disruptions on granite
Staters and that our constituents have
the right to hear a debate
would I now oppose the tabling motion by
pressing the red button thank
you the question is whether to lay House
Bill 526 on the table and this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button opposed press the red
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote chose 7 in the affirmative 146 and
a negative out spel 526 is laid on the
table
the majority of the committee on
transportation to which was referred
House Bill 133 FN an act modifying the
new Resident driver's license transfer
requirements specifying when the
Division of Motor Vehicles shall send
violation notices and appropriating
funds to the division for technological
upgrades required for legal compliance
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass representative Ted
Gorski for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Seth Miller for the minority of the
committee representative Miller's
recognized speak against the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker uh as a
first-term representative I had the Good
Fortune to participate in our new
legislator orientation just a couple
weeks ago and one of the things we one
of the sessions we had was about what
makes a good bill and we were given
three guidelines to work from that it is
a value to the residents of New
Hampshire that it is coherently CL
crafted with penalties and enforcement
appropriately specified and that it is
fiscally responsible this bill fails on
all three of those metrics the number of
people who are residents in the state
without changing their licensees limited
their presence does not present any
hardships to the state and and their
identity and qualifications to operate
Motor Vehicles remains confirmed by
their existing license the majority
committee report states that quote this
bill requires new residents to transfer
their out ofate driver's licenses to a
New Hampshire's driver's license end
quote it does not do that RSA 263
chapter 35 does that it is already the
law and already has defined enforcement
and
penalties speaking of enforcement and
penalties this bill does not bring any
to bear at best this bill simply creates
a lot of paperwork
there are rumors that some enforcement
details may follow in a second Bill if
the sponsors want enforcement or
penalties that should be included as
part of the initial conversation not
split out it is inappropriate to create
additional regulatory structure without
details on how it will be used nor
certainty that it will be used finally
the proposed legislation imposes
unfunded new costs on the department of
safety as we Face reduced Revenue
forecasts it is incumbent upon us to act
responsibly with the funds of the state
not to approve unfunded mandates that
burden constituents I you to join me in
opposing the OTP motion by pressing the
red button to vote no and request a
division vote thank
you representative PR recognized speak
in support of the committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker existing Law requires
new residents of New Hampshire to
transfer their out ofate driver's
license to New Hampshire within 60 days
however we have evidence this is not
being done back in 2017 the Secretary of
State and the commissioner safety
compared the voter database from the
November 2016 election with the DMV
database and issued a joint report
stating that 6,540 individuals presented
an out ofate driver's license while
using same day registration to
vote
uh roughly 10 months later when the
reports were examined well beyond the
60-day requirement of RSA 235
26335 only
15.5% had since received a New Hampshire
driver's license this is it is this
dismal 4.5% unexplained non-compliance
rate that this bill seeks to
address this bill attempts to address
this issue by doing two things first it
authorizes the sharing information on
voters who registered with an out ofate
driver's license on an ongoing basis so
the DMV can send them reminder
notices second it creates a requirement
for an individual who does not plan to
transfer their driver's license to
explain why to the DMV the 2017 report
identified a few legitimate reasons why
this could happen such as moving back
out of state or an elderly person who is
giving up their driving privileges
tracking these situations will permit
future reports to be more
accurate this bill is also in part a
follow-up to 2018 House Bill
1264 which clarified the definitions of
domicile and residency no laws
effectively making them the same thing
prior to this one could in certain
circumstances be a qualified voter
without being subject to RSA 26
335 this is no longer the case that law
has twice been before the New Hampshire
Supreme Court and both times the court
has addressed the interaction between it
and RSA 26335 is requirement to get an
instate driver's license within 60 days
and the court has indicated there are no
constitutional issues thank you Mr
Speaker and I urge everyone to press the
green
button the questions on the majority
committee report uh does a member yield
for a question member yields you may
inquire thank you Mr Speaker thanks for
taking my question what about members of
the
military thank you for the question um
military members vote at their home of
record this is also where they maintain
their driver's license and and all other
aspects of primary residence if a
military member has New Hampshire as
their home of record they should have a
New Hampshire's driver license and vote
here either in person or by absentee
ballot as needed we have a special
provision in RSA
2635 DB for members of the military
federal government employees and their
families to renew their New Hampshire
license by mail if they're a way in
orders uh if they're voting here the
driver's license should be issued in New
Hampshire period the Army website has a
good article explaining this and I've
provided that to the transportation
committee to answer any questions on
that and happy to provide it anyone else
who has a question as well thank
you representative representative
Miller's requested a division vote this
will be a division vote members take
your seats
representative Sweeney requests a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
now it'll be a roll call vote members
continue taking your seats
clear the questions on the majority
committee report about to pass on House
Bill 133 and this is a division vote
representative Sykes is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker sorry it's
a roll call vote
continue again thank you Mr
Speaker colleagues if I know that we
shouldn't be in the business of creating
laws to fix problems that are not
clearly and
authoritatively
delineated to prove that there is in
fact a a real problem and if I know that
when we create laws like this that
result in incredible expenditures it
wasn't laid out in the speech but I'll
lay it out a little bit more for you
this bill provides funding to put in a
new
position and also to upgrade technology
to do some parts of the work that it
would require it is a lot of money and
if I finally know that this is in
fact an unfunded mandate would I then
press the red
button representative Gorski is
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry hey thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know that data from past
election shows that we have a dismal 15%
compliance rate with our requirement for
new residents to get an instate driver's
license and if I
know this topic has been has been
addressed twice by the New Hampshire
Supreme Court in recent years and found
constitutional and finally Mr Speaker if
I know that the speak Secretary of State
testified in support of this bill at the
public public hearing would I press that
nice green button to pass the
bill the questions on the majority
committee report of House Bill 133 about
to pass this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
if you're opposed press the red voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the
vote 206 in the affirmative 147 and the
negative the committee reports
adopted House Bill 133 is referred to
the committee on
finance the committee on Transportation
which was referred House Bill 140 FN an
act establishing a voluntary blue
envelope program for drivers with autism
spectrum disorders having considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation ation
at the bill ought to pass with
Amendment the amendment is
0129 H printed in house record 10 on
page 30 the question is on the adoption
of the amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppos nay the eyes have it and the
Amendments
adopted the question now is on the
majority committee report of ought to
pass as amended on House Bill 140 are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I any oppose nay the eyes
have it and the committee reports
adopted good
time all
right e
the committee on Transportation which
was referred House Bill
259 an act relative to increasing the
number of handicapped license plates and
placards the Department of Motor
Vehicles May issue to individuals having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative Matthew pataro
for the committee the questions on the
majority committee report of ought to
pass you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I any oppose nay
the eyes have and the committee reports
adopted the majority of the committee on
ways and means to which was referred
House Bill 83 FN an act increasing the
minimum wage for sports betting having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate repres
Fred duett for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation at the bill a
you pass representative Thomas shamberg
for the minority of the
committee for what reason does a member
rise to make a motion State your motion
I moveed to lay HB 83 on the table
representative gerana moves to lay House
Bill 83 on the table are you ready for
the question all those in favor say what
you want a division he said he wants a
division he said he wants a division
this will be a division vote members
take your seats or a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded that is not sufficiently
seconded it'll be a division vote
a
all right the motion is to lay House
Bill 83 on a table this is a division
vote representative D is recognized for
a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I agree
with the majority report which suggests
that this topic is best suited for the
charitable Gaming Commission that we
will be taking up next and if I know
that adopting the itl motion uh would
have tied our hands for the rest of this
term but tabling this bill would
preserve our ability to address the
minimum age for sports betting next year
if the commission so recommends would I
now press the green button to table HB
83 thank you representative Dess
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know we have the opportunity to kill a
bad piece of legislation would I vote
right
on the tabling
motion the question is whether to lay
House Bill 83 on the table and this is a
roll call vote no a division vote it's a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button opposed press the red
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative
rolds representative rolds
present have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 147 in the affirmative 207 and
negative the motion
fails now back to the main motion of for
what reason does the member rise uh
thank you Mr Speaker uh move to
indefinitely postpone HB 83
representative Osborne moves to
indefinitely
postpone House Bill 83 are you ready for
the
question and representative Osborne has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded it is this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
again e
the question is whether to indefinitely
postpone House Bill 883 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button oppose press the red voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
representative
pza Al
[Music]
represent
Marco up or down
please representative up or
down have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the
vote 215 in the affirmative 140 in the
negative House Bill 83 is indefinitely
postponed
the committee on ways and means to which
was referred House Bill
328 and act establishing a charitable
gaming oversight commission having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative Fred
duette for the committee the amendment
is 0069 H printed on house record 10 on
pages 31 to
32 the question on the adoption of the
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I any oppos nay
the eyes have it the Amendments
adopted now the motion is the committee
report of AA pass as amended on House
Bill 328 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I any oppose
nay the eyes have it and the committee
reports
adopted recogn M thir reading motion the
chair recognizes the member from Auburn
representative Osborne for the third
reading motion thank you resolved that
the house now adjourned from the early
session that the business of the late
session be in order at the present time
that the reading of bills be by title
only and resolutions by caption only and
that all bills ordered a third reading
be read a third time by this resolution
and that all titles of bills be the same
as adopted and that they be passed at
the present time and when the house
adjourns today it be to meet Thursday
February 13th at 10: a.m. the questions
on the adoption of the third reading
motion you ready for the question all
those in favor say I
any oppos n the eyes have it and the
motion's
adopted one moment please we have some
announcements Representative Steven
Pearson's recognized for an
announcement thank you Mr chair the
licensing subcommittee on Edna is
meeting 30 minutes from right now in 302
in the
L representative ammon's recognized for
an announcement thank you Mr chair
emerging Technologies caucus tomorrow
Friday 2 pm check your email please if
you're part of the caucus thank
you representative lon's recognized for
an announcement thank you Mr Speaker the
pension subcommittee of Edna is meeting
in half an hour at room 305 our normal
room
one more thing so let's have quiet in
the room if you are going to
leave do it quietly please
representative Damon is recognized for
unanimous
consent thank you Mr Speaker colleagues
thank you I know I am one and a half
minutes away from you and a hopefully
not too slippery Road
I'm representative hope Damon I serve
the nine counts of Selvin District 8 I
intend these remarks to serve as a brief
reminder of Our obligation to hear our
constituents comments were made two
weeks ago by a committee chair
suggesting that online testimonies are
of less interest and value to our work
than in-person
presentations the observation was made
that organizations can efficiently
recruit many voters to participate
online and that somehow meant those
those folks opinions are of less Merit
these remarks continue to be disturbing
many voters have expressed considerable
distress to me and other members since
then to quote one
writer that testimony comes from real
Granite Staters working people parents
caregivers and others who simply cannot
drop everything to drive to conquer in
the middle of a workday public input
should not be limited to those with the
privilege of flexible schedules or the
AB ility to travel many New Hampshire
residents are balancing Jobs family
responsibilities and many other
commitments that make in-person
attendance in conquered impractical to
suggest that their voices matter less
just because they cannot physically be
in the room is both dismissive and
undemocratic your own constituents like
so many across the state rely on online
testimony as one of the few accessible
ways to engage with our government with
us dismissing their input does them a
disservice and undermines the Very idea
of representative democracy end quote I
want to assure the public that many
hopefully most New Hampshire elected
officials do pay attention to
constituent Communications regardless of
how they are shared we welcome your
participation in our legislative work
using any approach that works for you we
respect the challenges and busyness of
your daily lives and know it is not
always practical to travel to conquer to
speak personally transparency in
government is extremely important now
more than ever to that end I ask each of
my colleagues to routinely report
testimony numbers online testimony
numbers in committee executive session
before every vote we are here as
representatives of our constituents and
none of us should ever forget that thank
you for your kindness and respect as I
spoke Mr
Speaker what reason does the member rise
I move that the members remarks be
entered into the permanent
Journal all right members take your
seats there's going to be a vote on this
a roll call has been requested and it's
sufficiently seconded members take your
seats
members take your seats this is a roll
call vote Let's go people we were trying
to get you out of here before the Sleep
let's hurry it up
much here
the motion is whether to print the
remarks of unanimous consent this is a
roll call vote representative orz is
recognized for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I knew this was
another
de Mr Speaker if I knew this was another
attempt by those on the other side aisle
to pad the numbers which they don't have
and to continue to just prolong the
agony would I vote to oppose this thank
you very much we're going to vote
red representative Mount is recognized
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I believe that the vast
majority of my colleagues in this
chamber agree with the uh previous
remarks and I know that every member in
this body has the opportunity right now
to tell your constituents if you don't
would I vote green to allow the remarks
to go into the permanent
journal the house will be in
order this is a roll call vote on
whether to print the remarks if you're
in favor press the green button oppose
press the red voting stations are open
for 30
seconds e
[Music]
sorry folks people left their lights on
so I have to check
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 165 in the affirmative 104 in the
negative the house will be in order or I
will find ways to make this take
longer and the remarks will be
printed representative Osborne moves
that the house stand in recess for the
purposes of the introduction of bills
vacate motions enrolled Bill amendments
enrolled Bill reports and receive
receiving messages are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it the
motion's adopted and the house is in
recess until Thursday February 13th 2025
at 10:
a.m.
e
e for